[Musica]
[Applauso]
a
[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questa
nuova puntata ed ultima di sturgeon
simulator 2013
è stata una cosa incredibile arrivare
fino a questo punto raga ed oggi ci
teneva a fare una puntata pure in camice
c'era ma chi vi fa vide in camice tranne
me vabbè non ci ho messo un casinò bravi
tirarlo fuori perché era quello che
usavo quando facevo chimica e ovviamente
se la gente non mi chiamano ne consenta
nemmeno all'ultima puntata
[ __ ] allora vi giuro che prima di
prima di spegnere al finale prima di
uscire io a quelli ci rispondo perché
per una volta per una volta voglio
capire che cosa hanno da dire ogni volta
va bene allora ghazi siamo finalmente
giunti all'operazione nello spazio dopo
aver fatto 250 operazioni era ora che
dovessi fare questa allora prima di
tutto dovrei tirare fuori questo che
sono all'esame delle civiche aspetto ce
la posso fare la gara ma è difficile no
con la tastiera metto tutto dentro anche
la tastiera o chiaro lascia posso fare
buy back
ci siamo allora nile abbiamo guardato le
tue performance abbiamo bisogno dei
servizi in una missione speciale
inserendo questo disco ha consentito ad
aiutarci un agente di verla prendere
immediatamente non allarmarti vai cos'è
ci siamo stand bye bye ci siamo ragazzi
operazioni nello spazio
stiamo arrivando la vetta aspettato
troppo e ci siamo finalmente welcome to
space nine unova tu devi sai cosa fare
la ragazzina dobbiamo effettuare un
trapianto di cuore nello spazio non mi
chiedete perché
vabbè allora ragazzi ci siamo guardate
filo che guarda che roba c'è la terra
questa la cosa più fisiche che io abbia
mai visto comunque ragazzi siamo anche
trattenuti spin troppo direi di iniziare
la leggendaria operazione nello spazio
brutto stronzo
sei anche qui vero perché non ti hanno
mangiato gli alieni che figo c'era un
orologio che fluttua ok il quale in
quale mi serve merda mi è finito ancora
sul tetto
questo è un problema rabbia perché come
cazzo lo riprendo raga speriamo anche
volte ci si muove in basso il cuore
perché se lo abbiamo già perso in
partenza
e vabbè da dire iniziare dov'è il
martello ci sono le p ecco la martella
raga ma come li prenda radio il
possibile come faccio a prendere gli
oggetti devo fermo all'ora berman non
preso la sono presa lo spacchiamo il
torace con la cassa perché il martello
andato in orbita perfetto mai che ce la
fai
praga è impossibile allora bene forse
con la tazza non è proprio il massimo
ok se non si è rotto e così non si
romperà mai più devo prendere ma eccoci
anche il trap c'era il trapano ragali
non riesco a prendere gli oggetti come
quiz o iddio collisione e vabbè allora
farmi fare i fianchi fossati con farmi
carico a farmi che arriva a farmi che
arriva fermi che arriva no dove vai
fermo anche dp al volo dai bike si no
raga impossibile [ __ ]
allora che adesso ci siamo fermi
prendiamo sto maledetto martello profilo
rimaniamo allora ce l'ho fatta il
martello l'ho preso fermi che allora
devo chiudere cuore prima che scappa
devo riuscire a sputtana togliti tutta
sta merda inutile no mi è scappato il
morto
raga in possesso è tornato gioco ferme
allora troppe cose insieme calmi un
attimo allora il cuore sta scappando in
un deve assolutamente scappare perché se
no son cazzi comunque era che a quel
martello ci sto perdendo le speranze non
torna giochi maledizione non è possibile
è sto lanciando oggetti a caso che culo
assurdo si stava decapitando il paziente
bene i ragazzi il martello porca [ __ ]
non è possibile che ogni volta devo dire
allora fermi non è possibile allora tu
devi stare fermo
ok ce la possiamo fare non mi scappare
non non usare scapparmi stavolta by
scherziamo tutto non c'e nemmeno me ne
frega niente del quale proviamo prima
scattare perché marty alle più
importante sì perché se parte il
martello non esca far nulla allora vai
ce la stiamo facendo
ce la sto facendo era fermo cazzo mi
sarà allora perm in attimo devo riuscire
se allora via il martello devi prenderlo
al volo perché lo toglie no il quale sta
partendo via fares allora il cuore deve
star fermo lì grande sono riuscit a
incastrarlo non ci credo che culo dov'è
il martello dov'è il martin o che cosa
chiedo dove il martello che tanto non
scenderà mai più allora devo riuscire a
segare youth le ultime due ossa fai così
vai così vai te sto facendo
rimangono le ultime due ce l'ho fatta
alla perdita di qualità di sempre è
grande e viva il seghetto allora che
devo prendere un bisturi alla storia il
distretto del vice di tornate sulla
testa del paziente non mi chiedete come
ci è finito ora visto ha dimenticato di
togliere i polmoni giustamente o
riuscito a togliere i polmoni prima via
uno via l'altro è dedicata all'opera
senza è partita anche il fegato ragazzi
siano dove bis native gato via ed ora è
di studi prima che l'avevo preso eccoli
elimini nell'angolo calmissimi ragazze
possiamo fare calmi l'ho preso
raga ce la stiamo per fare allora devo
tagliare devo togliere il cuore ragazzi
già posso fare se non così alla fine non
ci credo è imposta in questa è la più
impossibile di tutte però devo riuscirci
devo dove cazzo si toglie l'ora fermi
ora non riesco non riesco a tagliare il
cuore perché l'ho preso ce l'ho fatta
agli ti porta [ __ ] che non servi più
dai che ce la possiamo fare ciò possiamo
fare luci credo pie e beve o cazzo
mancato il bersaglio va bene forse
meglio però lo accompagno se non rischio
di perderlo è già possiamo fare possiamo
fare vai vai vai vai spinge spinge 20
giu spingi gioco massaggio cardiaco
se non fatta ce l'ho fatta un cazzo
perché tanto il quale sta tornando su
quindi da volte ho chiuso la sega la
fine ma l'importante è che io ci sia
riuscito rai che è stata una cosa
impressionante è durata poco questa
puntata perché ovviamente la gara
soltanto un'operazione ma ci teneva a
tenerla per ultima quindi scusatemi se
la puntata è uscita accorta farò
laureato all'università fantastico è
perché non c'è scritto fa vj perché io
sono qua vj maledizione però vabbè c'è
un attestato cioè grande quindi ragazzi
sono veramente contentissimo sei video è
piaciuto
dai che ci siamo a rispondere a sto
maledetto il dolore fermi da datemi la
cornetta maledizione pronto
[Musica]
sono uscite tre parti no guardi io sono
il famosissimo e pluripremiato dottor
pavi jazz permettere
la vj non mi risulta devono è sbagliato
numero
no